first Wow what's up everybody welcome to
another AMA I am making a commitment to
try to be here for you guys every
Thursday to answer questions either
myself on an AMA like this where it's
just me
or I have special guests coming on to be
able to do some Q&A with so last week we
had Stephen Kelly next week we've got I
think Stephen Kelly again we're doing
we're doing back-to-back I guess where
the guests cleaned up and when there's
no guests you got me so hit me up with
your questions we'll see how long I stay
on here maybe we'll do half an hour
maybe we'll do an hour it depends on the
questions
welcome everybody say hi in the chat
Lily ma khari H top music Rahul give me
your questions who's up first let's see
how we're doing
first up is yah yeh hello sir how are
you I'm feeling great it's Thursday I
get to be here with you and so I'm
pumped
Lily MA how do I hire the best team Lily
MA getting us a first real question how
do I hire the best team well I have a
great video on this called the hiring
process is broken that I highly
recommend checking out I think most
people hire the wrong way I think people
hire for certain skills but they don't
pay enough attention to values and I
think if you're hiring somebody to be a
graphic designer for you as an example
how well they can create a resume in a
cover letter have very little to do with
their ability to actually perform the
job that you want them to perform for
you and so I don't put a lot of
credibility into resumes or cover
letters I think a lot of people who
apply for a job I don't even read the
job description they just apply and that
wastes a lot of your time in bringing
the right person on board so I leave
with a job posting that leans heavily in
with my one word I want somebody who
believes in entrepreneurs loves the
mission and then I'll bury some
questions in the middle of this giant
job posting so it'll say something like
how many YouTube subscribers do I have
and if somebody doesn't respond with
that answer I don't read their
application pretty simple you know you
want somebody who actually took the time
to read the java application if you're
gonna take the time to read what they
send in from there I hire people on the
trial project and you know maximum
twenty percent of the people it's it's
mind-boggling how many people don't even
read the Job Description so you get like
max 20% of the people usually less will
make it through the next round just
because they didn't actually answer that
question then I hire them on a project
and I give them something that I think
will take two hours and I give them five
hours to do it and I see who's kind of
milking me
he's who's either really slow at getting
stuff done or who was milking me and
puts in the full five hours and they're
just taking a long time to do it and
then from there I just see how how is
the working relationship how did they do
in that trial project usually somebody
blows me away and that's for saying the
hiring and so it's a really
unconventional hiring process but it
works I have a team of misfits who are
perfect fits for me and I highly
recommend checking out that video the
hiring process is broken because it goes
into a lot more detail on that all right
what else we got
yeah guys tag me in the question so it's
easy for me to see because it pops up as
orange for me Shea how do you push
forward when things are not going to
plan things never go to plan like first
of all except the things that never go
to plan as much as you plan and plan and
plan you got to realize that it's just
not gonna work out
as according to plan you know I made
this mistake in my first business I I
spend an entire summer
writing the perfect plan it was the
perfect plan and then as soon as we
launch we realize oh there's a lot of
things that just didn't go according the
plane and you got to adjust and so it
doesn't mean have no plan like you have
a plan you try to make it happen and and
along the way you adjust you know even
if I started this YouTube channel the
AMAs we're not part of the plan now they
are fur for the you know time being
we'll see if you guys like them I'll
keep doing them if you don't then I'll
adjust the top tens we're never part of
the plan and you know we did one I did
well
we started doing more and and we started
increasing the frequency and I've had a
lot of other things that didn't go to
plan most of the things that I try don't
work most of the new videos that I try
don't work we have more failures than
most people even try and it's just
getting over the fact that your plan is
not working like going knowing that your
plan will not work and you just adjust
and it's it's about what happens to most
successful entrepreneurs the plan they
start with is not the plan that they
finish with and that's okay you know if
you look at Wrigley's the gun company
they started selling soap and they were
given away I think it was baking powder
as as a bonus anybody bought soap got
baking powder and then everybody loved
the baking powder someone so they
started selling baking powder and
anybody who bought baking powder got gum
and then the gum was doing so well I
said okay forget baking powder myself
we're gonna sell gum and gum was the
thing that ultimately took off for them
BMW sold airplanes that's why their logo
is a propeller right their logo is the
blue and white and propeller because
they sold airplanes Lamborghini made
tractors and moved into high-performance
cars from tractors right it's like you
never know where it's gonna go the most
common thing that was that one the plan
is not gonna work out don't expect it to
and till you get started like just
because the plan is not gonna work out
doesn't mean you don't do anything you
get out there you try things and then
you adjust you adjust based on what the
market wants based and what people are
interested in and based on what you're
interested in because you don't know
exactly what you're gonna love and how
you're gonna love it until you actually
get into it it's like imagining the
perfect relationship how it's all gonna
play out and then you get into it and
you realize other things about that
person and about yourself
and so anybody who goes in thinking that
it's gonna just automatically work out
or think that the plan is gonna work out
and and if it doesn't work out life is
over you're gonna fail that's the wrong
mindset your plan will not work that's
okay just keep going and keep adjusting
don't get too hard on yourself
expect to fail and just make it better
every day make it better the next day
get up and make it better make it better
keep going
next again guys tagging the questions I
see some great
one's coming up Robin Evan can I be
successful on my own without a team of
employees so yes to a certain extent you
can only do so much on your own you know
when you're starting up a business you
have to do everything yourself I'm a big
believer in doing everything yourself I
don't think you should take out a huge
loan a mortgage your house or take on
investment dollars or you know borrow
money from your mom or whatever it is to
start your business I think you need to
do it yourself and that means your
everything from the CEO to the janitor
in your company right you your
everything and that's great and you want
to try to focus on like one thing
because if you're trying to do
everything you have tons of different
business ideas then you scatter your
time and you're spending little chunks
everywhere and you light little fires
but nothing ends up taking off and so
that's not the path it's finding what
you have that Michael Jordan level
talent at and focusing on that as much
as possible the thing is if you have a
big mission if you want to do something
much bigger then it's hard to do it all
on your own you know you can only grow
through certain size doing it by
yourself you've got to be able to build
on a team to do something much bigger so
that you can focus on the things that
you love so you know accounting is
usually one of the things that
entrepreneurs give up as soon as they
can we don't want to do a campaign and
in that accounting you know however
however long it takes you to do every
month the bookkeeping and accounting
that frees up your time to do bigger
things because you have genius level
talent at something when you're doing
everything yourself though you're
spending very little time on that right
maybe only 10% of your time is actually
spent on the thing that you are great at
and then 90% of time I spend on other
things that you can do but you're not
great at it and so if you really want to
have a big impact build a company you
know really make a difference the more
time you can spend doing the thing that
you love when you're great at the more
likely gonna be successful if I look at
my YouTube channels of example I started
everything myself everything I added I
researched I was in front of the camera
behind the camera everything and then as
I realized you know I don't like I don't
like doing all the research I don't like
doing all of the editing especially the
editing I really sucked the editing and
had no passion to get better at it at
all that allowed me to move from one
video a week
- one video a day when I hired an editor
I was able to go to a video a day I was
able to go you know seven times my
output by bringing on an editor and it
allowed me to have more fun and let me
have a bigger impact and now we're
making three videos a day most of the
time and that's because I have a team
who knows eight people who helped me on
my YouTube team and that allows me to do
more of the things that I love and I'm
great at and have a bigger impact if I
kept going the other way and making one
video a week doing everything myself
spending 90% of time on things that I
wasn't great at or wanted to be great at
I'd have a much smaller channel I'd have
a much smaller impact that be playing a
much smaller game I'd still be possible
I could still probably make some kind of
income from it but it's not really what
I was destined to do right and so I
believe that we all have some kind of
greatness inside us and if you could
figure out what that is and spend as
much time as possible doing that and
delegate the other things in your
business to the people who compliment
your weaknesses who love doing that who
love accounting who love editing who
love all the stuff that you hate it just
allows you to go a lot further and have
a bigger impact and I think if you have
the ability then you have the
responsibility and so that's something
that I try to push myself on every day
and so if you're asking yourself do I
need a team you know no but eventually
if you wanted something big then yes and
I'd look at what are you so afraid of
and building up a team and just because
it didn't work out the first time with
some hire or you're worried about being
a manager like those are real fears but
everything great comes on the other side
of facing your fears you can be a great
manager even though your first hire
didn't work out you know like the first
anything didn't work out you can be a
great leader even though you've never
let anybody before even though you might
be an introvert to not want to get up
and give motivational speeches right so
whatever that fear is if you have a big
goal in a big dream you're gonna have to
build a team eventually otherwise your
own limits will be reached and that
that's that next Amanda do you think
this is a good plan to discover my
strongest passion what was the plan I
didn't see the plan
above here's the plan just like you said
you'll never know what you like until
you try I'm considering working six
months in healthcare six-month and
marketing six-month in real estate six
month in law firm etc is that a good
plan
okay two-part question there uh yes and
no the yes is if you don't know what you
love then you need to go out and explore
you need to try things out you got to
say yes you got to take on new
opportunities and see what makes you
come alive if you have no idea the no
part is the six months like if you go
into market and then you just absolutely
hate it after three days stop and go do
something else right don't don't force
yourself to do it for six months look at
if you're really trying to find your
passion you're doing something every six
months that only is allowing you to do
two things a year that may not be good
enough like if if there's ten things you
need to try it's gonna take you five
years to figure it out that's crazy
right and so my barometer is really just
figuring out do I want to come back and
do this again don't put so much pressure
on it that it has to be the thing right
I think just like if you're dating your
first date if you have so much pressure
like this has to be the person I'm
marrying or moving on then you put so
much pressure on it and then you'll
you'll set yourself up for failure if I
look at salsa dancing as an example when
I first did that I just liked it you
know saying yes the whole bunch of
things I said yes it's also dance is it
yes the snowboard and I said yes to
trying a bunch of different things and
the barometer was just do I want to go
back and do it again did I have fun was
it enjoyable that I learned is it
challenging that I liked it
I went rock climbing and I hated it you
know I'm afraid of heights that the
harness was you know constricting and
then my crotch and you know like I just
everything about the experience is just
not fantastic for me and I get the
people love it that's amazing and and I
was happy I tried it once and and that's
it I don't need to go back I don't want
to pursue that anymore and I think it's
unfair to judge things before you go and
try it it's easy for me to say well I'm
afraid of heights so I shouldn't go off
and do that
I said yes I tried it but that's it I
know I don't want to go back salsa
dancing I wanted to go back and do more
and eventually you know how many years
later I
but I invested and then bought the
largest salsa dancing company in Canada
for sure maybe North America probably
North America YouTube you know when I
first started YouTube I made a video and
it was kind of fun so like okay let's
make another video and another video I
kept making more and that this is this
is this is good I want to make more like
it and then I saw the momentum this is
something that I could spend a lot more
time on I'm seeing results I'm it's
personally fulfilling and so I think if
you don't know what you want to do then
you need to go off and say yes you're
not going to figure it out by sitting on
the couch no I can figure it out just in
your head not just by thinking your way
through this problem you have to go out
and actually try stuff so when people
asked you to join them at an event or
try something new just go and try it and
don't worry about how it makes sense in
your career I never thought when in the
salsa dancing that I would eventually
invest in a business and take it over
never I just thought it was a fun thing
to do once I never thought I'd be at
almost a million subscribers when I
first started this YouTube channel
wasn't something I was thinking about so
don't put the pressure on it but also
don't constrict yourself to the six
months you know it's like if you're in a
bad relationship with somebody do you
want to wait six months just to see if
it if it gets better or works out you
know no like if it's if it's an abusive
relationship you get out as soon as
possible if if being in marketing is an
abusive relationship for you leave and
go do something else so I love the idea
of testing just not restricting to six
months next what do we have what do we
have amia is talent necessary so I think
I think talent you just develop I think
I think we all are born with certain
kind of you know innate abilities some
things that you can't control you know
you can't control how tall you are you
know if you want to go into the NBA then
you hopefully are taller but it doesn't
prevent you from be able to get in other
you know Muggsy Bogues was five
something I could dunk you know I think
I think though much more important than
talent is the work I think if you are
working hard every day you can develop
talent at almost anything and you'll see
that the people who are
at the top of their field are often not
the most talented but they put in the
most work like they weren't the most
naturally gifted with an ability they
just worked really hard to develop their
own I think that's much more important I
think look at the top of any field any
athlete any musician any entrepreneur
they just put him insane amounts of work
to get really really good at what
they're doing and looking at my youtube
channel as an example if you go back on
my videos I sucked at the beginning you
know I'm still on my journey I'm a lot
better than I was and I'll be a lot
better in five years if I continue but I
had no natural ability to do this to
make videos to be in front of the camera
I was nervous I was shy I forgot what I
was saying I felt I had to memorize
scripts I couldn't I couldn't speak with
anybody in the room in front of me I
would never do a live hangout like this
I was terrified to speaking in front of
an audience you know all of the stuff
that I didn't grow up with I never grew
up with any of this stuff and being
introverted that was also extra scary
for me I didn't enjoy that stress so how
did I get here work had like five
thousand videos right you know just keep
putting in the work get better get
better improve I think if you put in
enough hustle into anything you'll get
really good like if you do something
5,000 times you better get good at it
you'll just naturally you'll have to get
good at it because you're doing it so
often and whatever that goal is I think
too often people look at other people
ahead of them and say well they're just
naturally talented and so I have no shot
you have a shot you can you can crush
them you have to put in the work to be
able to do it what else
Andrew I started selling on eBay with
some success but it's not scalable
due to what you find the sell I think
drop shipping online is better should I
try both or focus on one eBay can be
sellable you said to make enough margin
like in any business and any business if
you're thinking about scalability you
have to be able to remove yourself from
the operations all right so if you can't
pull yourself out of your company then
all you've done is buy yourself a job
where you need to be able to pull
yourself out of the day-to-day hire
someone to be able to do it so you can
focus on continuing to grow the business
so that's not doable at the beginning
obviously it's just getting started but
as you're growing your company if you
are not continually increasing your
revenue and then get to the point where
you can say hey I can I'm making X
amount per year I can remove myself and
hire somebody to do my job and I'm
making a lot less but I still have some
profit but I freed up all my time to go
off and do other things or find other
ways to continue to grow the business or
within my eBay business I'm really good
at whatever you're really good at
sourcing products oh you're really good
at right in the descriptions they're
really good at doing the customer
service you're really good at like what
is the thing that you're really good at
and then hire for the other things out
both of the businesses can work it's
really more what you're passionate about
and where you feel like you can really
contribute the most value to what else
what do we got what do we got what do we
got what do you got low low legend low
legend yo do you think a one-man star
can be successful I don't know what that
is something limit I'm a one-man army
one-man startup wish you a great day we
need more these live streams listen I so
I feel like answer that question already
yes but if you want to have a big impact
and you have to do more you have to be
able to bring on a team I love the idea
of the one-man army so whenever I'm
starting something I don't default to
one mine are me I want to bring people
on board you know I want to be able to
build partnerships I want to be able to
have people help me and on my journey
what I'm doing whether that's somebody
volunteering their time or find them a
partnership or bringing on somebody to
join a team whatever it is but if
somebody says no if everybody's like no
that's crazy that's stupid you know they
don't want to join me I'll still do it
right like don't let the fact that
people reject you from you moving
forward on your plan I'll be the one-man
army and go off and create it because I
want to create it I will will it into
existence but it's not that I want to
default to that all the time because
people can contribute great things to
your business to your ideas to help you
build positive moment'
come forward on whatever you're trying
to build as well so I think I think you
mean both I think you want to be open to
bringing people on to help you but if
you don't get it that doesn't prevent
you from doing something you know you
will will it into existence regardless
what else 47 star
hey Evan thank you again what was the
most important power behind your success
what was the most important power behind
my success you know comes down the
belief for me comes down to the people
behind me they're my parents who just
helped me to believe in myself every
every major breakthrough that I've faced
in my business has come from me
believing more and more in myself in my
first business you know I was 19 I was
selling biotech software I didn't have a
science background or computers and I'm
selling the people you know three times
my age to have PhDs and I just didn't
believe that they would listen to me I
felt that was too young and then just
realizing that hey all they care about
is that I can help them and I have a
tool that can help them just making that
mental shift allowed me to go off and
start making some sales get some
distribution deals start building
positive meant to my business and taking
it from you know making $300 a month to
be able to have you know customers in 30
countries NASA Johnson Johnson
eventually being acquired and every step
along the way like me speaking in front
of an audience at the start I was
nervous and afraid and scared and didn't
think I could do it didn't think was for
me I'm not extroverted I'm not not
naturally talented at speaking all of
the all of the stories and then just you
know believe in myself a little bit to
go off and try it I realized I really
enjoyed it
and so every major breakthrough I've had
has just been belief in myself more and
you know the question I guess a lot when
I do interviews is what would you tell
you 20 old self or your 15 year old self
or your 25 year old self it's always I
just believe more like believe more
believe it's gonna work out believe just
go try it do it you know you believe in
yourself a little bit just believe
harder believe stronger believe more
makes a huge difference because you sit
on stuff like you sit on ideas that you
like that you want to try that you want
to implement
and then you don't do anything about
them usually because of the self-doubt
not enough belief I had a project that I
was thinking of launching this tip my
typical process I think of an idea and
then I think of who can help me so I
reached out to somebody who I thought
might be able to help me with it and she
wrote back to say that sounds really
cool what's your timeline on this when
you want to get started go back like
aisa happen what I think is something
there's no timeline it's not like let's
start in a month like no now as soon as
I think it's something it's immediate
how do we take immediate action moving
forward I don't I don't sit on things
period you know there's no this there's
a big plan of like hidden helping a
billion entrepreneurs it's a lifetime
goal but otherwise it's just go you get
an idea don't make it this big crazy
thing that is impossible to do just
start find some small way and start and
if and if she didn't want to do it or
she didn't want to meet or she didn't
want to she wanted to wait a week or
whatever like I would just start my own
and whether she comes on board and then
week great if not I find somebody else
if not I'll do it myself like start you
get an idea do something immediately
don't wait till tomorrow don't sit on it
don't wait to talk to friends don't wait
for anything else to happen just take
some kind of immediate action it's a
huge difference maker
next Henry Ernest Evan why don't you
have a podcast thank you for the love
Henry a couple reasons one I don't
consume podcasts I'm a visual person and
so I don't listen to any podcast I don't
I don't understand the podcast space and
so it's not something that has really
ever interested me I default to video
because I love visuals that's how I
learn better if you want to if you want
me to give you advice on something or
people on my team when they just read
something to me and I'm only hearing it
it's it's the hardest way for me to
learn like I have to really focus and
pay attention I often have to ask I'll
often have to ask them to repeat it or
like can you like show it to me because
if I read it if I see if I see the words
I comprehend better if I see a video or
comprehend better so that's one and two
is just focused you know why don't I
have lots of things
you know there's I'm drowning an
opportunity and it's a good problem to
have there's so many things that I could
do and if I try to do everything then I
do nothing well and so you know that's
really the focus right now is getting my
YouTube channel out it's getting my new
book top ten rules December 6 it's
running Toronto dine salsa it's
mentoring Lily with her business there's
a lot of stuff happening probably too
much to be honest of what I should be
doing and so tackling a podcast is not
it's not something that I could do well
right now now maybe maybe that changes
you know maybe I grow tired of YouTube
maybe like you know what this just isn't
working out anymore I got to find a new
challenge podcasting is the answer I
might get into it so we'll see but it's
been brought up a lot of times I
appreciate all the love and support and
and you know if you guys see
opportunities keep pinging me keep
putting on my radar because you never
know I may happen thank you for the love
next Amanda how do you feel about
franchises franchises really just
depends on what you're interested in
franchises one the idea of a franchise
is you're buying a business system
you're binds into something that works
right so if you don't have an idea of
something you want to do but you want to
you know kind of be an entrepreneur you
want to you know be your own boss then
franchising is a middle ground to be
able to go through there's pros and cons
you still have to work really hard you
still have to you know do all the things
that an entrepreneur does but you're
given a lot more guidance and help the
downside is you're restricted you know
there's a lot of restrictions on
franchises on what you can do how you
can market yourself the types of
activities that you can go through and
so for the super creative people that
can be a problem that is a limitation
I've talked to a number different
franchise owners and and I'll give them
advice say why don't you do this I got
we can't because you know head office
hasn't approved that and they don't like
when you do that so that that becomes a
challenge but if you just love following
rules you love having a system in place
then it can be a really good way to be
able to
quickly get off the ground as opposed to
figuring everything out on your own I
would just make sure that you pick a
good franchise if you're going to go
down that route tons of Rights crazy
tons of franchises are set up where the
actual business like business one the
first one isn't even making profits yet
so they may have had revenue they may
maybe they're making a million dollars
or ten million dollars or whatever it is
in their first location but they're not
profitable and so you don't want to
learn from that person you know you
don't want to learn from somebody who
hasn't built a profitable business
because whatever you do usually the the
franchisees are never as good as the
main operator typically and so they're
not even making money it's gonna be
really really really hard for you to
make money you got to put in so much
extra time energy effort hustle
creativity that if you're gonna do that
you might as well start your own
business right so the the benefit of
going with the franchise is you get a
proven system just make sure that it's
proven just make sure that they're
profitable make sure you're seeing
numbers of what not just what you can
expect not just projections of revenue
and profit for your location but that
they have already done it that the
person that you're listening to has
actually already built a profitable
business not just as good-looking
revenue lots of franchises are built on
quicksand and that's dangerous you know
that's that sucks and then you end up
carrying the bag with very little
support and if again you're that
situation rather we'll just start your
own business instead what do we got ash
weeny much love your video spread the
wisdom Thank You ash weenie why do you
think the world is full of chaos Wow why
do I think the world is full of chaos
I don't think I've been asked that one
before we're going deep um you know I
think people are just struggling to find
their place to be honest I think I think
a lot of people feel out of place I
think people feel like they have a lot
more potential inside them they don't
want to accept the life that they have
they're living the life that their
parents
want them to live or their culture they
may have tried some things and it didn't
work out and and now they're you know
resentful I think a lot of people just
feel stuck in life most people aren't
fulfilled in what they're doing and I
think the default I think human nature
is just to try to escape to try to run
away from a problem to try to blame
other people to complain about it to not
accept responsibility I think that's
just default human nature and as a
result you have a lot of chaos you got a
lot of people who are upset you have a
lot of people blaming other people you
have a lot of negativity and and
unhappiness in the world and you know
kind of rightly so like if your life
sucks and you're not doing what you want
to be doing and you're forced into some
position and you don't see any way out
if you feel like you're drowning it's
really hard to change your approach and
that's what I try to do with my videos
you know I think that the greatest
problem that humanity faces is untapped
human potential and so how do you fix
that how do you help people realize
their human potential well I'm a
believer a big believer the environment
matters the people you hang out with
matter the the habits and rituals and
routines that you have matter and I try
to create content that solves that
problem you know I can't be with you
guys all one one by one by one but if
watching one of my videos helps makes it
a little bit of a difference for you
whether it's me talking or Steve Jobs or
whoever and that becomes a daily part of
your routine as it is for me and that
starts to shift your mindset to say you
know what like I can I can control this
I can change things I can take more
responsibility I can make things better
for myself and the people around me if
you can move from the mindset of
escaping and complaining and negativity
to the place where okay this sucks where
I'm at right now but I'm gonna try to
make it better I'm gonna try to build
something better for the world then
that's when that's when good things
start to happen you know but it's why
why do people like watching Big Brother
17 and why do we like reading tabloids
and you know why do we like the
negativity and watching other people
fail so much it's because we don't like
our own life and when we see other
people doing poorly it makes us feel
better about our crappy life and so
instead of just moving from that
negativity I would encourage you to try
to use that time to build something
better for yourself invest in yourself
learn grow improve your environment
change your mindset learn new skills try
to build something better instead of
just escaping a life that you don't like
most people don't do that and so that's
what I'll try to change what do we got
Constantine Evan thank you for your
positive force that you bring to the
screen how do you feel about breaking
the rules so this is this is a great
question I like this question and I
think about my own example and I was
talking to Nina about this recently I am
a good follower of the rules when I feel
like the rules are smart so you know as
example in learning in learning material
so I you know I've gone to dance classes
obviously have a day in school I have a
personal trainer who tells me what to do
gives me rules if I feel like it's
working then I will follow the rules so
my personal trainer tells me to do
something I do it tells me to lift these
weights I do it tells me to eat these
number of calories I do it tells me to
download this app and install it I do it
you know when I was training with my my
agent who was teaching me about how to
be a better speaker every exercise he
gave me I did it it didn't always work
it wasn't always a great result but I
did it right like I trust him in the
process I trust in the flow and and I
got results as soon as I feel like I've
got it or this is a stupid rule or I
don't agree with it then then I'm the
worst student ever you know so sometimes
in dance classes when I feel like I got
it then I'm off doing my own thing I'm
experimenting and coming up with
something new I'm trying to add my own
flavor to it and so you know I think
rules were designed for the average
person right rules were designed for
maybe even the below average person add
something right
because if you don't know what to do
here's this easy rule for you to follow
so the design for the lower than average
person and when you first start things
you are worse than lower than average
you're at the beginning like you suck
right great like use the rules to help
you but as you get better and brighter
and faster and smarter and stronger at
those things then that's when you
realize the rules can't apply to you
anymore as much I'm you know let's let's
keep it within the rules of society
right we're not talking going out and
killing people or robbing banks or
anything but a lot of the rules may not
apply anymore because you've grown
beyond the standard you should like you
as you get better at something if we're
talking about the Michael Jordan level
of genius talent is something you need
to be on the cutting edge now like
you're you're now creating the new rules
right if I look at what I'm doing on
YouTube we've already applied all of the
best practices that other channels are
talking about and the experts are
talking about and so I don't have as
much respect or I don't listen as much
to the experts anymore the experts
because I'm already doing what they're
saying ain't them I'm doing more like
I'm teaching them I'm coming up with new
things on my channel that nobody's
trying and so I have to cuz to stay
ahead otherwise I just stay stagnant
right to keep growing to be the best
you've got it now innovate and come up
with your own new set of rules then
other people follow and that becomes
standard but there's lots of other
things if I was learning karate I would
follow the rules right like teach me how
do i how do i do karate how do i you
know III know nothing about karate teach
me right so I think it just depends on
what it is that you're trying to learn I
think just disrespecting all rules
period is not a smart idea
that's just understanding where you are
on the learning curve but also you know
when you start passing those those marks
when you realize that you're doing you
know you know but these rules may not
apply to you then breaking free and
starting to create your own rules and
dealing with the the negativity in
dealing with the dealing with the hate
from the people who follow the rules I
think I think you know when you're
breaking the rules
need to make sure that you're not
hurting somebody else you know you want
to make sure that you're following your
own path but not screwing other people
over in the process right to say like
the rules of the road Drive and don't
apply to me
well like you somebody may die because
of that you know you're like if you run
a red light and then they swerve and
smash into a pole that's a problem but
if you're you're breaking the rules to
try to make something better to realize
this is just a limitation and this is
better for me and better for you like
better for the world better for the
community better for the people who will
then follow the new rules right then
then I think that's good I like that
clarification what else
Alex hi Evan would you hi your family I
have my PI family I've had great
experience hire and family and hiring
friends just fantastic it doesn't always
work out for the long term but I think
it's just communication I think it
depends on your own style and just over
communication so as an example one of
the first guys I hired to do my website
was what was my best friend in school as
it was Andrew and we ran into some
challenges in that Andrew was an English
major and he cared about every single
word that he wrote and he would a
ganache over every single word that he
wrote and I needed content for my site
I'm like I appreciate the attention to
detail in the quality and I love that
but like he can't take two weeks to
write an article like I need I need we
need to get the content out we got to
get it going and it caused that was
probably the worst situation of anybody
that I've had to deal with in terms of
friends and family which so I'm bringing
it up but it just got to the point where
it's where we realize it's not neither
of us are happy right like I'm not
getting the results that I want terms of
the number of articles and he feels
forced and pressured to create something
that's not really what he wants to do
and so it's just communication it's just
being able to talk to each other and
realize hey this isn't this plan that we
designed here is not a fit and so can
you go off and do something else that
may help or is it better just to go
outside my company I think too often you
get people who are just in the wrong
position
and you don't talk about it then it
becomes a fight and it just keeps
building up to this huge fight and then
that could cause serious harm to the
relationship but I think friends and
family have a loyalty that you you know
that that takes time to build with
somebody else they have a care for what
you're doing it's it's a lot easier to
trust them and get going especially at
the start but you have to really do an
audit to see do you think that you can
work with this person is it going to
cause issues are you both open to
communicating and sharing what's on your
mind and where you're going and if
you're you know there are some situation
that if you are just at the at the
bottom and you really need help from
somebody a lot of times like your family
is the best place to go to your friends
and family the ones will have your back
and really want to champion and chew you
on and a lot of times when your lowest
low your family the ones who like just
keep pounding on you and say how crappy
you are great so those are not the
people who you want to have in your
business but if they're the kind of
people who build you up and always have
your back then those are great people to
have inside your company it's really
just about that over communication
making sure those little things don't
build up into big big big things next
guys if you tagged me it's a lot easier
for me to see because I see it in orange
so just put at Evan Carmichael so I can
see it more easily how should an
aggressive ambitious person turn into a
mentor or stay approachable and grounded
I find that people get scared of focus
people so you know one I would say you
want to you want to attract people who
share a similar focus to you if you are
around people who find you
unapproachable and just really hate the
vibe that's gonna be hard for both of
you right comes down to understanding
what your one word is like if your one
word is ambition then people will be
attracted to that who are also ambitious
but share different skill sets like if
you if you are creating YouTube videos
and you you have the ambition to be in
front of the camera you need the
ambitious guy behind the camera and the
ambitious the out girl doing the editing
all that stuff makes it a lot easier if
you have totally different values it
makes it a lot harder to move quickly as
a team and so it be you being upfront
with what you value or what you care
about in the kind of business that you
want to build so that you can attract
the right kind of people into your team
back to the very first question that
Lily asked that being said if you want
to build a team you also have to care
about people right so it's about the
mission and it's about the people you
have to care about them growing you have
to be somebody that is accessible right
somebody who wants to help like a great
leader sees the potential and the people
underneath them and helps build them up
right so you can use ambition to help
them if you if you're ambitious and
they're ambitious and you see more in
them than they see in themselves you can
bring them up to your level
but there's patience involved in that
and there's training and mentoring and
coaching and you have to want to do that
or at least have somebody on your team
who wants to build people up I think
it's important so I would just do a self
audit on yourself to see you know yes
you don't need to be able to relate to
everybody you know I don't really do
people who are who are super negative
I don't relate to complainers I don't
want complainers on my team I don't
people to come in and just whine about
everything that's happening in their
life you know I want people to take
responsibility and accept and then try
to make it better and build and grow and
I will I will hold your hand and I'll be
as patient as anybody to help you get to
where you want to go but I'm not I'm not
tolerating negativity and unhappiness
I don't patience for that and so
figuring out like where you draw the
line but at some point there has to be a
piece of you that wants to build a
mentor and train people because as you
build your company the people become
more important than you you know the
beginning you're everything because you
do everything but if you're building a
company you know if I look at my channel
now YouTube right we've got eight people
on my team to help me with that the
amount of work that they can ship you
compared to what I contribute like
they're giving more than I am you may
see me in front of the camera doing a
lot of stuff and I'm
still touching every single video but
net they're putting a lot more work and
they're bringing a lot more value than I
am and so if they're not happy if
they're not growing if they're not
learning that they're not stretching
then ultimately the company's not gonna
do well so it has to be a piece of you
that wants to build it
next fredo how to not care what others
when others don't believe in you so you
know that's a tough one and and I think
it's a muscle that you build you know I
think ultimately it depends on who the
person is but I don't know that ever
fully goes away you know there's always
a little piece of you that will that
will care what some people think I would
suggest a couple things I would suggest
one looking at the source and asking has
this person done what I want to do you
know so when is when it's somebody close
to you it's especially hard if it's if
it's somebody on the street who says you
will never be an entrepreneur it doesn't
mean anything to you because who is this
person to you but it was your mom saying
that you suck and you'll never be an
entrepreneur that makes it a lot more
challenging what I would look at though
is again the person who's given you this
feedback and advice have they done the
thing that you want to do so if it's
your parents saying that you will never
be a successful entrepreneur don't do it
well have they done it like what do they
know about being a successful
entrepreneur right do they does their
wait does their opinion hold any weight
have they have they achieved what you
want to achieve and if the answer is no
then their advice is meaningless their
opinion is meaningless right and and
it's a story over and over and over
again of a lot of entrepreneurs who's
you know parents didn't believe in them
but they went off and did it anyway and
so that that's my first kind of rational
rationalization through because at first
it stings to hear something like that
from someone close to you but if they
haven't done what you're trying to do
then their advice is meaningless and you
probably want to do the opposite of what
they suggest right because they just
don't have the experience - one thing
that helps is also understanding that
it's probably coming from a place of
love you know if your parents or your
friends don't
want you to be an entrepreneur they need
be really negative about it but but it's
oftentimes coming from a place of love a
place where they they just care about
you they want you to be successful and
happy just they want you to have it
their way because they see happiness and
success only through one limited lens
right this is the only way to be
successful and so I want this for you
and so they're being hard on you out of
love and just recognizing that at least
for me reduces the sting right just
recognizing that like okay this message
is not intended to be hated and negative
it's out of love they just have a
different perspective one that I don't
agree with and that can help calm you
down and get you through and then the
third piece of advice I have and and
maybe the most important is to start to
change your environment I would start to
consume resources ideas be around people
who make you feel the opposite who make
you feel like what you're doing is is
unstoppable that you have a chance to go
off and do it so if you know if it's
your parents telling you you can't do
something I would look at stories like
Michael Dell who was in university and
was wanted to start Dell computers and
he was gonna be a doctor and he you know
his parents really wanted him to be a
doctor because through their single lens
right like being a doctor that means
success and he convinced them to allow
him to try his computer company in the
summer I said if it does well I'm not
gonna go back to school but if it
doesn't do well I'll go back to school
and it took off and he never went back
to school and I'm pretty sure they're
they're happy with the success that he's
had since but surround yourself with
with that surrounding yourself with
people who have broken through those
stereotypes who have a a thick skin now
as a result of fighting a lot of battles
I think helps I think if you want to be
more confident you know as an example
you can you can read a list of seven
ways to be more confident but if you're
hanging around confident people you will
naturally just become more confident
right like you you become what you
associate with and so you may not have
friends doing
of important big things a lot of friends
who are you know bucking the trend this
is where for me the videos really help
or maybe it's books for you or maybe
it's something else
for me being around all these successful
entrepreneurs write these successful
people push me to want to do more push
me to want to be better I don't have a
lot of negative people around me but it
then is it's still easy to just to be
complacent it's still easy to just stay
where you are like if you're if you're
having the most success other your peer
group you're the big fish among your
friends then it's easy just to get lazy
and coast where every time I watch a
video on my channel these people are
hustling and doing big things it makes
me want to go off and do bigger things
right so I don't know these people you
know I never met Steve Jobs I've never
met Howard Schultz you know maybe one
day I will all not Steve but Howard but
I don't need to you know I call them
aspirational Mentors
and by consuming their content regularly
it it just makes me stretch and gives me
more belief and more confidence it's the
it's one of the main reasons behind the
new book right like the top ten rules
not to plug the book but the idea is to
read a page a day don't read the book
and like just flip through it like
another book read one page a day you're
gonna get two ideas from a genius level
talent entrepreneur who's made big
things happen in their life and if you
do that if you read a page a day if
you're watching a video day if you're
doing like it has to be daily it's not
enough to once a month go to a
conference and get all inspired and then
come back and fall back down to your
level it's gotta be daily whatever the
thing is it helps you feel the feeling
that you are you know unstoppable and
you don't care about the opinions of
other people daily and then as you do
that consistently daily just like
lifting weights you just get a little
stronger you may not notice it from day
to day but you you look back like a
month two months six months a year I
think I'm a lot stronger than I was
before right if you try to lose weight
right it doesn't happen overnight it's a
process right so the same thing if you
are continually feeding your your mind
with nourishment just like you would eat
healthy
then over time you'll notice a big
impact and you will care less about what
other people think and you'll have more
confidence it makes a huge difference
the environment matters it's so so so so
so important and that applies to any
challenge that you're facing if it's the
fear of getting started or if it's lack
of confidence or you know what people
think about you judgment by being around
people who have overcome it and are
overcoming it just by being around them
by consuming that stuff instead of what
you're consuming right now which is the
hate and negativity and you know the
message is your friends and family are
telling you you know you want to try to
reduce those messages you may not be
able to eliminate it because you know
you still want to talk to your mom but
reduce as much as possible and then fill
the void with something that's uplifting
and if you don't have that in friends
around you then get it from books and
get it from videos and get it from
movies and get it from songs and just
get it from your heroes be around your
heroes more and you'll become more like
them you'll adopt not not you won't be
them but you'll become more like them
and be a better version of yourself
there we go what do we got what do you
got what do we got that was a good that
was a good answer
Toronto greenhouse Howard is awesome
what Elon is my fav yeah
listen whoever it is that makes you come
alive like that's you want to study and
what I would encourage you guys to do
you know so I have on my wall I got
Steve Jobs Howard Schultz my parents AP
Giannini Kanye West you know you may not
know some of these people chances are
well you don't know my parents and you
probably don't know AP Giannini and
maybe you know Howard Schultz that's
okay like these people mean something to
me when I walk into this office this
means something to me when I find
somebody that I really resonate with I
look for more of their content so Howard
Schultz was a great example you know I
have a I love Howard Schultz I love his
message I have a Alert on YouTube so
whenever a new video or interview comes
up with Howard I get an email and I
consume it and I learned something from
it
naveen jane is another one I'd never
heard of this guy he's Indian
billionaire he's trying to be the first
trillionaire trying to go to the
in China these big projects never heard
of him we did a top-10 on him it did
okay what it didn't crush it's not it's
not didn't do as well as a lot of our
other videos he's still not a super
known quantity but for whatever reason
his style his message his approach
really resonated with me and so I
subscribed to him too
now he doesn't have his own YouTube
channel but he's on other people's
channel so I get an alert every time he
does an interview and so when you find
somebody that really resonates with you
because a lot of the people on my
channel have the same message just the
way they deliver it with the level of
intensity or care or whatever it is just
some people really connect with you more
than others when you find those people
trying to find a way to be around them
more right so if you love Elon Musk like
I love Howard Schultz you love ulamahs
Elon Musk is gonna be on your wall
Howard Schultz is on mine great be
around the LMS as much as possible like
you're not gonna go work at Tesla maybe
will but if you want to be an
entrepreneur you're not gonna get a job
at Tesla you know as far as I know
Elon Musk doesn't have a coaching
program that you can sign up for so so
how do you do it
well you see the seal and musk have any
books
does he have an autobiography have
people written about him are there
videos on him right so we've done two
top tens I think on Elon we've done some
mentoring some Elon that's a great
starting point I would subscribe to any
alerts that if he does a new interview
or does a new speech you get notified
and so you have a constant influx of
Elon Musk's coming into your inbox if
you if you love Elon Musk if he's your
hero and he makes you think big and
you're bold and you're you're more
confident because of it and you consumed
a little bit of Elon every day for 10
minutes 15 minutes you would you would
change you would not recognize yourself
a year from today if you did that every
day like those small daily consistent
habits will change you and so if there's
people that you get exposed to from my
channel or other places I highly
encourage you to go look them up I go
find out who that person was Alex on my
team at TDS saw some video with Daniel
DiPiazza he's a he's a young guy he's
been on my channel and he just loved
Daniel's message it's like great that
guys
name is Daniel D Piazza Golda come up
he's got a YouTube channel go subscribe
to him he's got a book go buy the book
like if that guy's message reached you
where somebody else doesn't cool learn
more from that guy like make that part
of your daily routine to inject it into
your head because again if you're around
that that vibe if you wake up and you do
something that makes you feel bold and
confident every single day your life
will change if you do that consistently
do that consistently for a year your
life will be so dramatically different
what you've accomplished the way you've
gone your level of happiness the impact
you're having on others will just
dramatically change and I've seen it for
myself I've seen you for the people
around me and it's part of why I do my
channel right like for you guys if you
make it habit to watch it consistently
and be around positive people who are
trying to do amazing things in the world
like you can't help but have some of
that seep into you to want to go off and
do something better and if my channel
doesn't do it for you great like do the
thing that makes you come alive that's
what's most important
what are we else what up what did I say
what do we else gods I got too excited
by my last point I forgot how to speak
English what are we else what do we got
here what else
Fisher Fisher project projection can I
become a leader when nobody sees me as a
leader absolutely the whole question is
you know it's crazy the fact that like
you would limit yourself based on what
somebody else sees you at you got a
break free of that mindset there's a
great quote it was from Quincy Jones who
said not one ounce of my self-worth
depends on on what other people's
opinion of me is the minute you start
making your life choices based off what
somebody else thinks about you that's
when you start to lose like that's game
over you will have to do things that
other people think is crazy is
impossible but you want to go off and do
it and and listen it may not work like
the first time you try something it may
not work but if you're if you want to be
a leader and nobody sees you as a leader
then you need to get working on becoming
a better leader right like at the start
if you have zero leadership skills
you're gonna
suck as a leader at the beginning you
just will because you don't know what
you're doing
and that's fine but every day you're
gonna try to work a little bit more a
little bit a little bit stronger a
little bit better and learn research
write read books by great leaders watch
videos by great leaders practice being
in leadership opportunities one of the
greatest things about about leadership
is you don't have to be appointed a
leader to be a leader right you don't
have to people don't have to vote you in
to be a leader leaders rise up when
there's an opportunity to be a leader
like when there's a when there's a
vacuum of leadership and often the
leader who's supposed to be in charge
socks of being a leader too so take take
practice daily in your life you know
when you see an opportunity to be a
leader jump in and do something about it
a leader sees a problem and goes in and
fixes it and it could be a tiny minor
little problem or it could be a much
bigger and larger problem but the more
you practice on the little ones then the
more comfortable you get to be able to
go after the big ones so as an example
Alex another Alex story at EVs there was
this fight that was breaking out and
there's security guard right next to the
fight and he wasn't doing anything he
didn't break it up he didn't try to get
involved and you know he should be the
leader that's his job to go off and
break up this fight right like keep the
peace you're you're the security guard
you should be doing this you're paid to
do this and he didn't and everybody else
is just walking by and Alex decided I'm
gonna go and break this up I'm gonna get
in the middle I'm gonna be a leader in
that little micro moment and so he broke
them up and so you'll have those chances
every single day to be a leader and it's
a question of whether you accept them or
not whenever you see a void a lack of
leadership now start to think to
yourself I'm gonna jump in and I'm gonna
solve it I'm gonna be the solution so
those two things one you know accept the
suck at the beginning and then fill your
head with as much knowledge around
leadership as possible and watch
leadership videos and and watch people
who are great at leading and then to
practice
practice practice practice practice
daily find little opportunities to step
up and be a leader it's not it's not a
zero to 100 it's not like you suck and
then you're great it's not whoever you
think is a great leader if you think
Howard Schultz is a great leader
you don't become Howard Schultz
overnight it's the daily steps that you
take to slowly get better and so I think
a lot of people want to go from zero to
100 and they feel like they can't and
then they suck and they're always going
to be a zero so how it works
you go from zero to one to two to three
to four you keep building up to get
there you got Melissa I've been
Carmichael Carmichael great live
learning so much his channel is my daily
inspiration thanks Evan and the crew I
appreciate that
arm the creative this is a nice break
from just watching regular videos much
appreciate it so this is this is an
experiment right and we talked I've
talked about a little bit on this live
stream already but you try new things
it's a creative outlet so this is a
third one that I've done the goal is to
have every Thursday something for you
guys so you can ask questions you can be
online you can you know we can do some
Q&A weather with me like this
solo or whether I have a guest on I
think the next couple weeks I have
guests on and after that'll be back to
me and we'll have some fun and if you
guys like it you're getting value then
we'll keep doing it and if you say Evan
this sucks you suck never do this again
if that's the collective opinion then
then I'll stop so listen guys it's been
an hour it's been a ton of fun
I really appreciate spending time with
you hopefully you got some questions
answered and you know I want to
encourage you to just put more
importance on what you're doing today
that today matters that you could do
something really important today there's
still a huge chunk of time left on the
day and not just coasts not just slack
off not just you know say okay well you
know the day's almost over like what you
can do today really matters I want you
to make something today that your
grandkids will be proud of like whatever
you're making today you want to show
your grandkids again if you take that
approach every day the stuff you will
make will be insane so thank you guys
for the love I believe in you I hope we
continue to build
in yourself and whatever your one where
it is much love guys have a great day
I'll see you soon